So are there any worse problems than undecidable ones?
Well, that kind of depends on your subjective view,
but from a perspective of computer science
undecidability is the biggest and meanest monster of complexity;
for a computer, there's no worse thing than
"I can't do it."
Which is undecidability, so the answer here is no,
but that also means
that you have completed your journey,
which means that all that remains to be said is
Congratulations for completing our Introduction to Theoretical Computer Science!
I consider this to be a rather challenging course,
so you should really be proud of yourself
for having learning so many advanced concepts.
You have learned about NP complete problems, some of the toughest problems
that are out there, and you have also learned how to recognize these problems,
so detecting NP completeness.
You have also learned how to navigate around NP completeness
using techniques such as search trees,
pre-processing, fixed parameter tractability,
approximation algorithms, and other techniques
such as randomized algorithms,
and finally, and this is all but trivial,
you now even understand the cliffs of undecidability.
I hope I've conveyed to you for many problems
that are very, very challenging to solve,
digging deeper into underlying algorithms
and techniques
can really be rewarding, because not only is it fascinating,
but actually, problems that to many people will seem unsolvable
can be solved using the tools that you've now learned.
Theoretical Computer Science or the science of challenging problems
is a very rich and deep field
and you're no ready to dig deeper.
Whether you want to dig deeper into the theory
or you want to dig deeper into writing your own algorithms
to solve nearly impossible problems,
that is up to you, but in any case,
I wish you all the best for that journey,
and once more, congratulations for completing this course.